es una noticia que ha generado muchísima
conmoción en argentina es algo inusual
aquí en el país es una intoxicación
masiva y simultánea de estas
características con una droga ilegal en
este caso con cocaína cocaína adulterada
eso es lo que entienden las autoridades
que fue lo que causó esta intoxicación
masiva a mucha gente apareció muerta en
sus casas en la calle el miércoles por
la noche vi a decenas de personas e
internadas en tratamiento algunas en
estado muy delicado por esta
intoxicación la información que hay es
que todos parecen haber comprado un
mismo proveedor en un mismo lugar él no
está claro todavía qué es lo que ocurrió
exactamente hay una hipótesis de la
investigación que tal vez se trató de
una adulteración por parte de otra de
otro grupo narcotraficante una suerte de
sabotaje eso es algo que se irá
confirmando a medida que avancen las
investigaciones y un mensaje de las
autoridades a quien tenga quien haya
comprado cocaína que la descarte de
inmediato